Speaker 1: All right, welcome to the show,
it's going to be a big, big vaccine show
today. Why? Because the approval of the Fizer
vaccine by the FDA happened. We said yesterday
it was expected to happen yesterday. It happened
within hours of us recording the show, publishing
the show. And important to remember, this is
this is Pfizer. Moderna is a few weeks behind,
but a very, very important development
for a number of different reasons. The New
York Times reporting the FDA grants full
approval to the Pfizer biotech covid-19
vaccine. The FDA granted full approval for
the Pfizer vaccine for people 16 and older,
making it the first to move beyond emergency use
status in the United States. As we talked about
yesterday, about a third of those refusing the
vaccine said if and when there is full approval,
they will go and get the vaccine. And so now
it's time to figure out whether they really will.
We are going to talk about the vaccine
requirements that are coming down as a result.
And The New York Times also pointing out the
decision is sure to set off a cascade of vaccine
requirements by hospitals, colleges, corporations
and others. The Pentagon responded immediately,
saying all active duty service members
will be required to be vaccinated.
Oregon has adopted a vaccine requirement
for state workers. In a brief speech Monday,
President Biden said he hoped the approval would
prompt many of the roughly 85 million Americans
who are unvaccinated and eligible for shots
to get them. So what are the important things
to remember? I already mentioned this is the
Pfizer approval many people have gotten. Moderna
Moderna is not yet fully approved, still
approved under emergency use. Moderna a few
weeks behind in the pipeline. They filed for full
approval shortly after Pfizer did. And it would
be expected that within a few weeks that vaccine
would be approved as well. Again, important to
remember that what the FDA has approved here
is the two dose regimen, which is the standard
emergency use regimen for both the Pfizer and
the Moderna vaccine. There are people writing
to me and I briefly addressed this yesterday.
Well, so they've approved the two shot regimen,
but they're already talking about a third dose
at the eight month mark. Immunocompromised
folks have already started getting a
third dose. There's Israeli data about
the efficacy of a third dose that's not currently
approved fully. And the expectation is that Pfizer
will immediately ask for that third booster shot
at the eight month mark to be approved as well.
For now, the World Health Organization is leaning
towards stick with two, let's use those would be
third doses and get them to countries and to
people that haven't even had a single dose yet
that's going to help us get out of the pandemic
more quickly. It's not a crazy thing to suggest,
but in the United States, there is going to
be the availability. I got my flu shot at CVS
the other day and the pharmacist said we have the
supply. They do Moderna at least that CVS did.
And they said once you're at eight months, you can
just come get a third dose. We're not going to be
restricting it to certain groups or whatever
the case may be. So now we'll start really
there's now we're branching. We had one branch
office which was waiting for full approval. We
now have that that's been met. We now have two new
branches to look at. One, do the people who said,
I'll get it once it's fully approved, do they
stick to what they said? My prediction is some do
and some move the goalposts. We already saw some
of the goalpost moving yesterday. It was exactly
as I predicted it was the approval too quick?
Was the approval politicized? Was the approval
rushed? The question being asked on Fox News, a
guest on Steve Bannon's program saying this isn't
even really an approval. We'll get to all of that
later. That's number one. And then number two,
we are we were expecting and we're already seeing
and we'll talk about it later on in the program.
A whole bunch of new organizations putting in
place vaccination requirements. We're seeing
more schools and colleges. We're seeing more
cities, say even just to go to restaurants.
And I'm curious to see, will there be hotel
chains that say this is a vaccinated only hotel?
That sounds pretty good to me. I would lean
towards going to that hotel chain if I needed
to go to a hotel and there was a chain that did
that. Is there an airline that's willing to be
the first to say, you're going to need a vaccine
to fly with us after a certain date? I would be
very interested in trying to fly that airline.
And it should not come as a shock that there
are millions of people who will say, I would
never do that. I will quit my job if they say or
I will never fly that airline or whatever. I
think for some of them that will apply, but for
many others as soon as it becomes inconvenient.
To be unvaccinated, they are going to go and
they are going to get themselves vaccinated
because people value convenience significantly
and we're going to talk about that a little
bit later. But next, I do want to talk about
the Pentagon mandating vaccination for all one
point three million active duty service members.